The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So we're through
with techniques of integration,
which is really the most
technical thing that we're
going to be doing.
And now we're just clearing up
a few loose ends about calculus.
And the one we're going
to talk about today
will allow us to
deal with infinity.
And it's what's known
as L'Hôpital's Rule.
Here's L'Hôpital's Rule.
And that's what we're
going to do today.
L'Hôpital's Rule it's also
known as L'Hospital's Rule.
That's the same name, since
the circumflex is what you
put in French to omit the s.
So it's the same thing,
and it's still pronounced
L'Hôpital, even if
it's got an s in it.
Alright, so that's
the first thing
you need to know about it.
And what this
method does is, it's
a convenient way to calculate
limits including some new ones.
So it'll be convenient
for the old ones.
There are going to be some
new ones and, as an example,
you can calculate x ln
x as x goes to infinity.
You could, whoops, that's
not a very interesting one,
let's try x goes to 0
from the positive side.
And you can calculate,
for example, x e^(-x),
as x goes to infinity.
And, well, maybe I should
include a few others.
Maybe something like ln x
/ x as x goes to infinity.
So these are some examples
of things which, in fact,
if you plug into
your calculator,
you can see what's
happening with these.
But if you want to understand
them systematically,
it's much better to have this
tool of L'Hôpital's Rule.
And certainly
there isn't a proof
just based on a calculation
in a calculator.
So now here's the idea.
I'll illustrate the idea
first with an example.
And then we'll
make it systematic.
And then we're going
to generalize it.
We'll make it much
more-- So when
it includes these
new limits, there
are some little
pieces of trickiness
that you have to understand.
So, let's just take
an example that you
could have done in the very
first unit of this class.
The limit as x goes to 1
of (x^10 - 1) / (x^2 - 1).
So that's a limit that
we could've handled.
And the thing
that's interesting,
I mean, if you like this
is in this category,
that we mentioned at the
beginning of the course,
of interesting limits.
What's interesting
about it is that if you
do this silly thing, which is
just plug in x = 1, at x = 1
you're going to get 0 / 0.
And that's what we call
an indeterminate form.
It's just unclear what it is.
From that plugging, in
you just can't get it.
Now, on the other hand,
there's a trick for doing this.
And this is the
trick that we did
at the beginning of the class.
And the idea is I can divide in
the numerator and denominator
by x - 1.
So this limit is
unchanged, if I try
to cancel the hidden factor
x - 1 in the numerator
and denominator.
Now, we can actually carry out
these ratios of polynomials
and calculate them by
long division in algebra.
That's very, very long.
We want to do this
with calculus.
And we already have.
We already know that
this ratio is what's
called a difference quotient.
And then in the limit, it
tends to the derivative
of this function.
So the idea is that
this is actually
equal to, in the
limit, now let's
just study one piece of it.
So if I have a function
f(x), which is x^10 - 1,
and the value at 1
happens to be equal to 0,
then this expression that we
have, which is in disguise,
this is in disguise the
difference quotient,
tends to, as x goes to 1, the
derivative, which is f'(1).
That's what it is.
So we know what the
numerator goes to,
and similarly we'll know
what the denominator goes to.
But what is that?
Well, f'(x) = 10x^9.
So we know what the answer is.
In the numerator it's 10x^9.
In the denominator,
it's going to be 2x,
that's the derivative
of x^2 - 1.
And then were going to have
to evaluate that at x = 1.
And so it's going to
be 10/2, which is 5.
So the answer is 5.
And it's pretty easy to get from
our techniques and knowledge
of derivatives, using this
rather clever algebraic trick.
This business of
dividing by x - 1.
What I want to do now is
just carry this method out
systematically.
And that's going to give us
the approach to what's known
as L'Hôpital's Rule, what--
my main subject for today.
So here's the idea.
Suppose we're
considering, in general,
a limit as x goes to some
number a of f(x) / g(x).
And suppose it's the bad
case where we can't decide.
So it's indeterminate.
f(a) = g(a) = 0.
So it would be 0 / 0.
Now we're just going to
do exactly the same thing
we did over here.
Namely, we're going to divide
the numerator and denominator,
and we're going to
repeat that argument.
So we have here f(x) / (x-a).
And g(x), divided by x - a also.
I haven't changed anything yet.
And now I'm going to write
it in this suggestive form.
Namely, I'm going to
take separately the limit
in the numerator
and the denominator.
And I'm going to
make one more shift.
So I'm going to take
the limit, as x goes
to a in the numerator, but I'm
going to write it as ( (f(x) -
f(a)) / (x - a).
So that's the way I'm going
to write the numerator,
and I've got to draw a
much longer line here.
So why am I allowed to do that?
That's because f(a) = 0.
So I didn't change
this numerator
of the numerator any by
subtracting that. f(a) = 0.
And I'll do the same
thing to the denominator.
Again, g(a) = 0, so this is OK.
And lo and behold, I know
what these limits are.
This is f'(a) / g'(a).
So that's it.
That's the technique and
this evaluates the limit.
And it's not so
difficult. The formula's
pretty straightforward here.
And it works, provided
that g'(a) is not 0.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
question is, is there
a more intuitive way of
understanding this procedure.
And I think the short
answer is that there
are other, similar, ways.
I don't consider them
to be more intuitive.
I will be mentioning
one of them,
which is the idea of
linearization, which goes
back to what we did in Unit 2.
I think it's very important
to understand all of these,
more or less, at once.
But I wouldn't claim
that any of these methods
is a more intuitive
one than the other.
But basically
what's happening is,
we're looking at the linear
approximation to f, at a.
And the linear
approximation to g at a.
That's what underlies this.
So now I get to formulate for
you L'Hôpital's Rule at least
in what I would call the
easy version or, if you like,
Version 1.
So here's L'Hôpital's Rule.
It's not going to be quite
the same as what we just did.
It's going to be
much, much better.
And more useful.
And what is going
to take care of
is this problem that the
denominator is not 0.
So now here's what
we're going to do.
We're going to say that it turns
out that the limit as x goes
to a of f(x) / g(x) is
equal to the limit as x goes
to a of f'(x) / g'(x).
Now, that looks practically the
same as what we said before.
And I have to make sure that
you understand when it works.
So it works provided this is one
of these undefined expressions.
In other words, = g(a) = 0.
So we have a 0 / 0
expression, indeterminate.
And, also, we need
one more assumption.
And the right-hand side,
the right-hand limit exists.
Now, this is practically
the same thing
as what I said over here.
Namely, I took the ratio of
these functions, x ^ x^10 -
1 and x^2 - 1.
I took their
derivatives, which is
what I did right here, right.
I just differentiated
them and I took the ratio.
This is way easier
than the quotient rule,
and is nothing like
the quotient rule.
Don't think quotient rule.
So we differentiate the
numerator and denominator
separately.
And then I take the limit
as x goes to 1 and I get 5.
So that's what I'm
claiming over here.
I take these functions,
I replace them
with this ratio of
derivatives, and then
I take the limit
instead, over here.
And it turned out that the
functions got much simpler
when I differentiated them.
I started with this
messy object and I
got this much easier object
that I could easily evaluate.
So that's the big game
that's happening here.
It works, if this limit makes
sense and this limit exists.
Now, notice I didn't claim that
g, that the denominator had
to be nonzero.
So that's what's
going to help us
a little bit in a few examples.
So let me give you
a couple of examples
and then we'll go further.
Now, this is only Version 1.
But first we have to
understand how this one works.
So here's another example.
Take the limit as x goes
to 0, of sin(5x) / sin(2x).
This is another kind
of example of a limit
that we discussed in the
first part of the course.
Unfortunately, now
we're reviewing stuff.
So this should reinforce
what you did there.
This will be an easier
way of thinking about it.
So by L'Hôpital's Rule,
so here's the step.
We're going to take
one of these steps.
This is the limit, as x goes
to 1, of the derivatives here.
So that's 5 cos(5x)
/ (2 cos(2x)).
The limit was 1 over
there, but now it's
0. a is 0 in this case.
This is the number a.
Thank you.
So the limit as x
goes to 0 is the same
as the limit of the derivatives.
And that's easy to evaluate.
Cosine of 0 is 1, right.
This is equal to 5 cos(5*0)--
And that's a multiplication
sign.
Maybe I should just
write this as 0.
Divided by 2 cos 0.
But you know that that's 5/2.
So this is how
L'Hopital's method works.
It's pretty painless.
I'm going to give you
another example, which
shows that it works a little
better than the method
that I started out with.
Here's what happens if we
consider the function (cos x -
1) / x^2.
That was a little
harder to deal with.
And again, this is one of
these 0 / 0 things near x = 0.
As x tends to 0, this goes to
an indeterminate form here.
Now, according to
our method, this
is equivalent to, now I'm
going to use this little wiggle
because I don't want to
write limit, limit, limit,
limit a million times.
So I'm going to use
a little wiggle here.
So as x goes to 0, this is
going to behave the same way
as differentiating
numerator and denominator.
So again this is going to
be -sin x in the numerator.
In the denominator,
it's going to be 2x.
Now, notice that we
still haven't won yet.
Because this is
still of 0 / 0 type.
When you plug in x
= 0 you still get 0.
But that doesn't
damage the method.
That doesn't make
the method fail.
This 0 / 0, we can apply
L'Hôpital's Rule a second time.
And as x goes to 0
this is the same thing
as, again, differentiating
the numerator and denominator.
So here I get -cos
x in the numerator,
and I get 2 in the denominator.
Again this is way easier
than differentiating
ratios of functions.
We're only differentiating the
numerator and the denominator
separately.
And now this is the end.
As x goes to 0, this is -
-cos 0 / 2, which is -1/2.
Now, the justification
for this comes only
when you win in the
end and get the limit.
Because what the theorem says
is that if one of these limits
exists, then the
preceding one exists.
And once the preceding one
exists, then the one before it
exists.
So once we know that this one
exists, that works backwards.
It applies to the
preceding limit, which then
applies to the very first one.
And the logical structure
here is a little subtle,
which is that if the
right side exists,
then the left side
will also exist.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Why does the
right-hand limit have to exist,
isn't it just the derivative
that has to exist?
No.
The derivative of the
numerator has to exist.
denominator has to exist.
And this limit has to exist.
What doesn't have to
exist, by the way,
I never said that f
prime of a has to exist.
In fact, it's much,
much more subtle.
I'm not claiming
that f'(a) exists,
because in order to
evaluate this limit,
f'(a) need not exist.
What has to happen is that
nearby, for x not equal to a,
these things exist.
And then the limit has to exist.
So there's no requirements
that the limits exist.
In fact, that's exactly
going to be the point when
we evaluate these limits here.
Is we don't have to evaluate
it right at the end.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the question
that you're asking
is, why is this the
hypothesis of the theorem?
In other words,
why does this work?
Well, the answer is that this
is a theorem that's true.
If you drop this hypothesis,
it's totally false.
And if you don't
have this hypothesis,
you can't use the theorem and
you will get the wrong answer.
I mean, it's hard to express
it any further than that.
So look, in many cases
we tell you formulas.
And in many cases
it's so obvious
when they're true
that we don't have
to worry about what we say.
And indeed, there's
something implicit here.
I'm saying well, you know,
if I wrote this symbol down,
it must mean that
the thing exists.
So that's a subtle point.
But what I'm
emphasizing is that you
don't need to know in
advance that this one exists.
You do need to know in
advance that that one exists.
Essentially, yeah.
So that's the
direction that it goes.
You can't get away with
not having this exist
and still have the
statement be true.
Alright, another question.
Thank you.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So I'm getting
a little ahead of myself,
but let me just say.
In these situations here,
when x is going to 0 and x
is going to infinity.
For instance, here
when x goes to 0,
the logarithm is
undefined at x = 0.
Nevertheless, this
theorem applies.
And we'll be able to use it.
Over here, as x goes to
infinity, neither of these--
well, actually, come to think
of it, e^(-x), if you like,
it's equal to 0 at infinity.
If you want to say
that it has a value.
But in fact, these
expressions don't necessarily
have values, at the ends.
And nevertheless,
the theorem applies.
I mean, it can exist.
It's perfectly OK
for it to exist.
It's no problem.
It just doesn't need to exist.
It isn't forced to exist.
So here's a calculation
which we just did.
And we evaluated this.
Now, I want to make a
comparison with the method
of approximation.
In the method of
approximations, this Example 2,
which was the example
with the sine function,
we would use the
following property.
We would use sin u
is approximately u.
We would use that
linear approximation.
And then what we would have here
is that sin(5x) / sin(2x) is
approximately (5x)/(2x),
which is of course 5/2.
And this is true when
u is approximately 0,
and this is true
certainly as x goes to 0,
it's going to be a valid limit.
So that's very
similar to Example 2.
In Example 3, we managed to
look at this expression (cos x -
1) / x^2.
And for this one,
you have to remember
the approximation near x =
0 to the cosine function.
And that's 1 - x^2 / 2.
So that was the approximation,
the quadratic approximation
to the cosine function.
And now, sure enough,
this simplifies.
This becomes (-x^2 / 2)
/ x^2, which is -1/2.
So we get the same answer,
which is a good thing.
Because both of these
methods are valid.
They're consistent.
You can see that neither of them
is particularly a lot longer.
You may have trouble
remembering this property.
But in fact it's something
that you can easily derive.
And, indeed, it's related
to the second derivative
of the cosine, as is
this calculation here.
They're almost the same amount
of numerical content to them.
So now what I'd like to
do is explain to you why
L'Hôpital's Rule works
better in some cases.
And the real value
that it has is
in handling these other
more exotic limits.
So now we're going to do
L'Hôpital's Rule over again.
And I'll handle these functions.
But I'll have to rewrite
them, but we'll just do that.
So here's the property.
That the limit as x goes to
a of f(x) / g(x) is equal
to the limit as x goes
to a of f'(x) / g'(x).
That's the property.
And this is what
we'll always be using.
Very convenient thing.
And remember it was true
provided that f(a) = g(a) = 0.
And that the
right-hand side exists.
But I claim that
it works better,
and I'll get rid of these.
But I'll write them
again to show you
that it works for these.
So there are other cases.
And the other cases that
are allowed are this.
First of all, as indicated
by what I just erased,
you can allow a to be equal
to plus or minus infinity.
It's also OK.
So you can take the limit
going to the far ends
of the universe.
Both left and right.
And then the other
thing that you can do
is, you can allow f(a) and g(a)
to be plus or minus infinity.
Is OK.
So now, the point is that we can
handle not just the 0 / 0 case,
but also the infinity
/ infinity case.
That's a very powerful
tool, and quite different
from the other cases.
And the third thing is
that the right-hand side
doesn't really quite have to
exist, in the ordinary sense.
Or, it could be plus
or minus infinity.
That's also OK.
That's still information.
So if we can see where it
goes, then we're still good.
If it goes to plus
infinity, if it
goes to 0, if it goes
to a finite number,
if it goes to minus infinity,
all of that will be OK.
It just if it oscillates
wildly that we'll be lost.
And those calculations
we'll never encounter.
So this basically
handles everything
that you could
possibly hope for.
And it's a very
convenient process.
So let me carry
out a few examples.
And, let's see, I guess the
first one that I wanted to do
was x ln x.
So what example are we up to.
Example 3, so Example
4 is coming up.
Example 4, this
is one of the ones
that I wrote at the beginning
of the lecture, x ln x.
This one was on our
homework problem.
In the limits of
some calculation.
But so this one, you
have to look at it first
to think about what it's doing.
It's an indeterminate
form, but it sort of
looks like it's the wrong type.
So why is it in an
indeterminate form.
This one goes to 0, and this
one goes to minus infinity.
So, excuse me,
this is a product.
It's 0 times minus infinity.
So that's an indeterminate
form, because we
don't know whether the 0
wins or the infinity this
could keep getting smaller
and smaller and smaller,
and this could be getting
bigger and bigger bigger.
The product could be
anything in between.
We just don't know.
So the first step is to write
this as a ratio of things,
rather than a product of things.
And it turns out
that the way to do
that is to use the
logarithm in the numerator,
and the 1 / x in
the denominator.
So this is a choice
that I'm making here.
Now, I've just converted it
to a limit of the type minus
infinity divided by infinity.
Because the numerator is going
to minus infinity as x goes
to 0+ and the denominator 1 /
x is going to plus infinity.
Again, there's a competition,
but now it's one of the forms
to which L'Hôpital's
Rule applies.
Now I'm just going to
apply L'Hôpital's Rule.
And what it says is that
I differentiate here.
So I just differentiate the
numerator and denominator.
Applying L'Hôpital's
Rule is a breeze.
You just differentiate,
differentiate.
And now it just
simplifies and we're done.
This is the limit as x goes to
0+ of, well, the x^2's cancel.
This is the same as just
-x. x factors cancel.
And so that's 0.
The answer is that it's 0.
So x goes to 0 faster then
ln n goes to minus infinity.
This 0 was the winner.
Something you can't
necessarily predict in advance.
So let's do the other two
examples that I wrote down.
I'm going to do them in
slightly more generality,
because they're the
most fundamental rate
properties that
you're going to need
to know for the next section.
Which is improper integrals.
And also they're just very
important for physical math,
and any other kind
of thing, basically.
So here, let's just do these.
So let's see, which one
do I want to do first.
So I wrote down the
limit of x e^(-x),
but I'm going to make
it even more general.
I'm going to make it
any negative power
here, where p is some
positive constant.
Now again, this is a product
of functions, not a quotient,
a ratio, of functions.
And so I need to rewrite it.
I'm going to write
it as x / e^(px). p
And now I'm going
to apply, well,
so it's of this form
infinity / infinity.
And now that's the same as the
limit as x goes to infinity
of 1 / (p e^(px)).
So where does that go?
As x goes to infinity.
Now we can decide.
The 1 stays where it is.
And this, as x goes to
infinity, goes to infinity.
So the answer is 0.
And the conclusion is that x
grows more slowly then e^(px).
As x goes to infinity.
Remember, p is positive
here, of course.
It's the increasing
exponentials.
Not the decreasing ones.
Let's do a variant of this.
I'll do it the opposite way.
So I'm going to call
this Example 5'.
It really doesn't give
us any more information,
but it gives you just a
little bit more practice.
So suppose I look at
things the other way.
e^(px) divided by, say, x^100.
Now, this is an infinity
/ infinity example, again.
And you can work
out what it's doing.
But there are two ways
of thinking about this.
There's the slow way
and the fast way.
The slow way is to
differentiate this 100 times.
That is, right?
Apply L'Hôpital's Rule over and
over and over and over again.
All the way.
It's clear that you could do
it, but it's kind of a nuisance.
So there's a much
cleverer trick here.
Which is to change this to the
limit, as x goes to infinity,
of the e ^ e^(px/100) /
x, to the 100th power.
So if you do that, then we just
have one L'Hôpital's Rule step
here.
And that one is that this
is the same as, ...as x goes
to infinity of, well it's
p/100 e^(px/100) divided by 1,
all to the 100th power.
That's our L'Hôpital step.
And of course, that's
(infinity / 1)^100.
Which is infinity.
Now, again I did this in
a slightly different way
to show you that it works
with infinity as well.
So that was this other case.
The right-hand side
can exist, or it
can be plus or minus infinity.
And that applies to this limit.
And therefore, to
the original limit.
And the conclusion here
is that e^(px), p > 0,
grows faster than
any power of x.
I picked x^100, but obviously
it didn't matter what power I
picked.
The exponents beat
all the powers.
So we have one more of the ones
that I gave at the beginning
to take care of.
And that one is the logarithm.
And its behavior at infinity.
So I'll do a slight
variant on that one, too.
So we have Example
6, which is ln x,
and instead of dividing by x,
I'm going to divide by x^(1/3).
I could divide by any
positive power of x,
we'll just do this example here.
So now this, as x
goes to infinity,
is of the form
infinity / infinity.
And so it's equivalent
to what happens
when I differentiate numerator
and denominator separately.
And that's 1 / x, and
here I have 1/3 x^(-2/3).
1 / x, and then 1/3 x^(-2/3).
Now, when the dust settles
here and you get your exponents
right, we have an x^(-1),
and this is an x x^(-2/3),
and that's a 1/3 becomes a 3.
So this is what it is.
And that's equal to 3x^(-1/3).
Which we can decide.
It goes to 0.
As x goes to infinity.
And so the conclusion is that
ln x grows more slowly as x goes
to infinity, than x x^(1/3)
or any positive power of x.
So any x^p, p
positive, will work.
So log is really slow,
going to infinity.
It's very, very gradual.
Yeah, question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The
question is, how many
hypotheses do you need here?
So I said that, and I think
what you were asking is,
if I have this hypothesis, can
I also have this hypothesis.
That's OK.
I can have this hypothesis
combined with this one.
I need something
about f(a) and g(a).
I can't assume nothing
So in other words, I have to be
faced with either an infinity /
infinity, or a 0 / 0 situation.
So let's see.
The rule applies in the 0 / 0,
or infinity / infinity case.
These are the only two
cases that it applies in.
And a can be anything.
Including infinity.
Plus or minus infinity.
The rule applies
in these two cases.
So in other words, this
is what f(a) / g(a) is.
Either one of these.
And in fact, it can
be plus or minus.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: And the right-hand
side has to be something.
It has to be either finite
or plus or minus infinity.
So you need something.
You need a specific
value of a, you
need to decide whether
it's an indeterminate form.
And you need the
right-hand limit to exist.
It's not hard to impose this.
Because when you look
at the right-hand side,
you'll want to be
calculating it.
So you want to know what it is.
So you'll never have problems
confirming this hypothesis.
Alright.
Let me give you one
more example here.
Which is just slightly trickier.
Which involves, so here's
another indeterminate form.
That's going to be 0^0.
So there are lots of these
things where you just
don't know what to do.
And they come out in
various different ways.
The simplest example of this is
the limit as x goes to 0 from
above of x^x.
In order to work out what's
happening with this one,
we have to use a trick.
And the trick is this
is a moving exponent.
And so it's appropriate
to use base e.
This is something that we did
way back in the first unit.
So, since we have
a moving exponent,
we're going to use base e.
That's the good
base to use whenever
you have a moving exponent.
And so rewrite this
as x^x = e^(x ln x).
And now, in order to figure
out what's happening,
we really only
have to know what's
going on with the exponent.
So remember, actually
we already did this.
But I'm going to do
it once more for you.
This is ln x / (1/x).
And that's equivalent,
as x goes to 0,
to using L'Hôpital's Rule
to 1/x, and this is -1/x^2,
which is -x, which goes to 0.
As x goes to 0.
And so what we have here
is that this one is going
to be equivalent
to, well, it's going
to tend to what
we got over here.
It's e^0.
That exponent is what we want.
As x goes to 0.
So that's the answer This
limit happens to be 1.
That's actually
relatively easy to do,
given all of the power
that we have at our hands.
Now, let me give you
one more example.
Suppose you're trying to
understand the limit of sin x /
x^2.
If you apply L'Hôpital's
Rule, as x goes to 0,
you're going to
get cos x / (2x).
And if you apply L'Hôpital's
Rule again, as x goes to 0,
you're going to get - sin x / 2.
And this, as x goes
to 0, goes to 0.
On the other hand, if you look
at the linear approximation
method, linear approximation
says that sin x
is approximately x near 0.
So that should be x / x^2.
Which is 1 / x, which
goes to infinity.
As x goes to 0, at
least from one side,
minus infinity to
the other side.
So there's something fishy
going on here, right?
So this is fishy.
Or maybe this is
fishy, I don't know.
So, tell me what's wrong here.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the claim is that
the second application
of L'Hôpital's Rule,
this one, is wrong.
And that's correct.
And this is where you
have to watch out,
with L'Hôpital's Rule.
This is exactly where
you have to watch out.
You have to apply the test.
Here it's an indeterminate form.
It's 0 / 0 before
I applied the rule.
But in order to apply
the rule the second time,
it still has to be 0 / 0.
But this one isn't.
This one is 1 / 0.
It's no longer an
indeterminate form.
It's actually infinite.
Either plus or minus, depending
on the sign of the denominator.
Which is just what
this answer is.
So the linear
approximation is safe.
And we just applied
L'Hôpital's Rule wrong.
So the moral of the story
here is look before you L'Hôp.
Alright.
Now, let me say one more thing.
I need to pile it on
just a little bit, sorry.
So don't use it as a crutch.
We don't want to just
get ourselves so weak,
after being in the
hospital for all this time,
that we can't use, I'm sorry.
So remember that you shouldn't
have lost your senses.
If you have something like
this, so we'll do this one here.
Suppose you're trying
to understand what this
does as x goes to infinity.
Now, you could apply L'Hôpital's
Rule five times, or four times.
And get the answer here.
But really, you should realize
that the main terms are sitting
there right in front of you.
And that there's
some algebra that you
can do to simplify this.
Namely, it's the same
as 1 + 2/x + 1/x^5.
And then in the denominator,
well, let's see.
It's x.
So this would be dividing
by 1/x^5 in both numerator
and denominator.
And here you have 1/x plus
2 over, sorry I overshot.
But that's OK.
2/x^5 here.
So these are the main
terms, if you like.
And it's the same as 1 /
(1/x), which is the same as x,
and it goes to infinity.
As x goes to infinity.
Or, if you like,
much more simply,
just x^5 / x^4 is the main term.
Which is x.
Which goes to infinity.
So don't forget
your basic algebra
when you're doing
this kind of stuff.
Use these things and don't
use L'Hôpital's Rule.
OK, see you next time.